so this talk is uh by shukho i am not
certain if i'm pronouncing your name
right i'm so sorry if i'm not
uh okay thank you uh it'll be about
turning pandas data frame to semantic
knowledge graphs right
and um when you go through our website
you can find all these links to connect
with you on different platforms and
it's
time goes back to youtube take it away
yes thank you so um
yeah as you can see from this uh
beautiful beautiful background picture
there we have some cute pandas um so the
talk will be about um what we all love
pandas um but uh how to power it up like
to make it you know um to be more
flexible so we can even like you know
deal with some complex structure
so
um
the slice is available if you're
interested in getting the slices there
um also i am contactable by twitter if
you
have further questions you can pop it in
the slacks i would be
in the slacks
during the conference time but otherwise
you can still contact me my contact
details are here
so
um i'm czech
i love open source
projects so i
i have been involved in various projects
in the past actually my first
contribution i think is
to pander so thank you pandas
that bring me to open source world um so
right now i'm very lucky i work um for
an open source graph database terminusdb
which um
you know everything is on github yay
i'm just happy
also i um i'm also you know i'm here if
i did global but i'm also like helping
out in um euro python um i'm one of the
board member last year this year
i mean yeah the coming year
and then um you know i'm organizing
another conference uh pyjamas um
in december yeah so
um
also i stream on twitch during the
pandemic i am doing it last nowadays
because i just love going outside um
we're outdoor even though today is
raining but you know
i miss people i miss all of you so um
hopefully i will see all my uh friends
uh in um
london chapter in prison very soon um
so pajamas con from what it is so it's
the conference that you can wear your
pajamas
so um the idea is that you know well
before the pandemic or after the finale
we will still be doing it online 24
hours
so worldwide
it's free streaming
so all the details you can find on
pyjamas.live register ticket now for
free um so that's it like advertisement
done um let's go back to pandas they're
so cute um
so why do we love pandas um well
of course the cube but uh well for the
two of handers
is very powerful when you have a um
a 2d i would say 2d because it's tablet
data
um so
a lot of times data scientists will use
uh
something called csv i assume all of you
know about it um and also you know or
similar things like uh you know excel
spreadsheet we don't like them so much
not as much as pandas but uh excel
spreadsheet is a common thing google
spreadsheet is more and more common
nowadays even like you know sql
databases you know sometimes um you have
different tables in a database
relational database so um a lot of times
you know we have to do some kind of
statistical analysis
of all these data then the easiest way
of course is import them into um as a
pen's data frame so you can use it in
your python code um you can you know
find all the answers of your questions
um
also the good thing about it is that
when you import the data it would try to
find what type the data is right so
there's an automatic type conversion
here
um
you know especially when you have
daytime conversion because
if you have deal with daytime you know
it's a messy business because time zone
and all these like different formats
that people use so
you can actually have a parsing logic
put in there and then panda will do that
for you
um or something even more automatic you
know um whether something is a number
whether something is just a string
you know um that that's that's quite
good so panda is very very
you know simple um you know
straightforward too
um but
some of you may came across something
like this how beautiful it is it's um
it's hard when pandas failed uh when you
have
normally a json format file
most of the case would be like you have
some api you're scraping something you
know just getting data from an api
you'll come back in a json format and
then you okay convert it to data frame
yay and then it become like this uh it's
because the reason why it is like this
is a json format usually is uh nested so
json think of it as dictionary you can
have another json mini json inside json
um you can have multiple layers of stuff
so
um it's not flat it's not 2d it's not
what uh
like it's not like a csv it's not what
uh pandas is
you know is
normally deal with so that's why when
you just directly put that into a um it
handles data frame it will look like
this uh which is not what you want right
you may want a summary as a column you
may want um let's say the issue type as
a column and then maybe the issue link
and then there's issue id so everything
needs to be
a column right um and then you have
different values in it um so yeah this
is a picture i get from my blog post so
this blog post teach you how to flatten
it up so it kind of become more readable
um but
um that also needs some like kind of
menu like handling because if it's more
than one layer nested then you have to
find that column that is still nested
like this and then flatten it further so
um it's
not that great it's not designed to do
this
um so
um
yeah so this is whoa exploding so this
is a um graph uh that we have um
in in terms db we have uh you know
uh once in a while we have this internal
hackathon we will just do some projects
together just have fun um so this is
what we did last year i believe is a
long time ago so we have all these um
they are uh different civilizations in
the all human history it doesn't matter
like whether you are in you know asia or
in you know um america you know other
civilizations they have conflicts right
because you know um humans are like this
and then we would just fight with each
other sometimes and um there the
conflicts so
um historian will have to maybe study
this um
and the best way to put it is something
like what i'm showing you on screen
right now is that something interactive
i can drag it around for example i'm
interested in what's the conflict here
that i can zoom in
sorry
sometimes it doesn't listen to me that
well so yeah it's like you can zoom in
to a certain civilization and see okay
what conflicts
this civilization this civilization is
having um so
uh we need something store like data
store in this like graph format we call
it um of course uh
python users know that there are other
tools uh you know network x and
obviously they also deal with graph uh
but now x is more useful uh graph
analysis but not for visualization or
stalling it actually because well it's
in memory right using python so
um yeah so how what's the what is well i
won't say the best way but another way
to deal with it so
um we use symmetric knowledge graph so
terminus db is a design based on
symmetric knowledge graph is a graph
structure just like what you have seen
in the last slide um
it store the interlinking of different
um
information for example we have
civilizations they have conflict with
each other
you also see some color code as well
that would also represent for example
whether that is something that's written
in history that is known or it's
something that is unknown but yet to
discover or
we know that it's not possible to
discover any evidence of it so
no unknown so
yeah so historians we
know about that but um
but yeah like uh you can store all these
different like relations between them
you can store some metadata about them
uh also the data type will be
uh really like uh solidly uh described
uh via a schema so
schema basically is just a plan to tell
you what you should be expecting the
data to look like um so it kind of store
these like um
you know what a property a data like a
data point or a document in our term so
we i have explained it yesterday in the
workshop so there are recordings i don't
know whether that would be available but
if you're interested you can go there um
so yeah we have um so everything is um
we store all together a schema and then
the data graph so everything is well
defined there's no
ambiguity like you know a csv you know a
series of digits could mean a an integer
or it could just be a number that should
be stored as a string because we don't
want to the missing trillion zeros
right so i have come across that problem
quite often so well
yeah um
so
so now like let's think about let's
think about it because like i
what i'm doing with terminusdb is that
i'm uh you know developing the python
client so i'm thinking how i can make
the life of everybody using terminusdb
much easier so how about
we can convert things like a pandas data
frame on uh you know then convert it
into a graph that i can store in terms
db and then the other way around
so um that's what i've been doing um so
this is so by the way this is all based
on my personal experience by developing
this tool of course you may have a
better idea of how it should be done or
this may not apply to your case when you
have to convert a graph into a data
frame
or vice versa but this is just my
experience so hopefully give you some
idea what you may have to pay attention
to
but it's no mean the the correct answer
or something like that so
this the screen aside so
um
so in terms of db like i said it's it's
a semantic knowledge graph there will be
a schema that describe how the graph
should structure it so we have to think
about what the schema should look like
before we actually put the data in right
so um
well if you are converting a data frame
or a csv um in this case so
it's a flash structure so it's actually
not not not that complicated
compared to the other way around which
you have to flatten the 3d structure
this is just you know you have a 2d
structure that can already naturally sit
in a 3d kind of situation so this is
good
um also the other thing to be
careful about is that the data type
because um well as pandas we know that
all the data type you can
yeah you can see it or you can get the
information about them by using dot d
types right so
um but you know but in terms db we have
to store them in a schema so we have to
get this d types information
back uh into a um
back to a data first of all the data
format need to be one that terminusdb
can recognize so for example the
pandas use numpy types numpy daytime 64
for example
then terminusdb won't be able to
recognize it so
but what we have is that the python
types
there is already a conversion from the
python types to terminus db
which
is using xs the xsd type so for those of
you who really want to dig deeper you
can look at x
xsd type so there's a full and other
like is another com common conversion
that's you but used by another group of
developers you can go there and see
they have a website so um
yeah
but you know
in this uh in this case we just need to
convert
the numpy type uh to the python type so
uh a
small trick i use is that actually um
there is a dictionary in numpy that
store the type conversion from numpy
type to python type which is type
dictionary
on there so i can just use it
um
and also
that's only covered the data types which
is just like playing types that like for
some integer string daytime all this
stuff but there's also link data which
is um a document or an object has a
property that is another
document or object so um this we call
that link data so usually they will be
referenced by an id of some sort so
if there is then i need to link them up
right so that's something that we have
to bear in mind if that's the case so
now
once we construct the schema then we
have to think about how to load the data
so um the few things to worry about for
example size limitation we know that
pandas work in in-memory so
it's not unlimited
so or is actually small relative to
other
storage um kind of solution like a
database could have a better a bigger
capacity than your local um ram in your
computer so um we have to do things in
pad batches a lot of times so that would
be something that to be aware of
um so for example in this case if i have
a very big csv if i load it into a
you know a pandas data frame
actually pandas provide a very very good
tool to allow you to load um your data
in chunks so it's just uh well it's it's
a small thing that people may not
realize because we normally just use
three csv csv right but if you put in
the chunk size there you it will
actually become a
iterator that you could loop over so you
become a reader that you could um
load your data in chunks
so um but there is a problem coming
with it is that for example you have a
column that
is a um
it's a digital like with with a decimal
number right so some something could be
like 0.5 or something but a lot of them
are zero so the data very sparse um
that could if the whole chunk of your
data for example let's say 100 of them
is a very small chunk but 100 of them
all of them are zero then that would
become a um
a
an integer
and then when you read the next chunk
which got a 0.5 in it for example then
there's a data type mismatch which is
something that we want to avoid so
finding a good
chunk size is important also
always be aware of your data
we should all always you know not just
do things like blindly always you know
understand your data before you do
anything
um that complicated
um
also you can um
well the next thing that i would do is
to export that in records because i want
to have that json crazy json structure
back
um so
again appenders provide a very good um
you know you can make it into dictionary
and then use the orient orient equals to
record there are few options you have
for uh to dictionary but um records is
the one that we use because um then we
can have each row as an object um which
is how we model things in terminus db
so
another things that data scientists love
or hate is n a's so um how
what when how should we deal with na so
i have free strategy here
that i give the user an option to do it
so first of all if um
if you really hate any or your data
should not have ndna uh if you rather
for example if there's one na in any of
the
records or um rows you would rather drop
the whole record or the whole row then
this is one of the options you can do
you can drop it
just like that
or you can make it optional because like
you can the other way around is that oh
this column can have missing data right
so uh you can declare that in terms db
that's another advantage to store
data in a graph is that
in pandas you would just have any there
right so it's it's a bit um some
sometimes we don't like it um but in um
in the graph format you can have that
property as missing you can but you have
to set it in the schema to say that oh
it can be missing
so
optional is another option um the other
thing is that when i automatically read
this csv
or pandas data frame when i try to
convert it i will just flow an error or
give the you know the steering wheel
back to the user so
like if they're data scientists they may
want to clean the data a little bit more
or if they're developers they may want
to
see what causes this and then maybe they
want to replace some of the missing
value with some dummy values so
um
so how about the other way around so um
so this is so far is quite
straightforward because again we put a
2d flat structure into a 3d master
structure so
it's not as difficult so the other way
around we want to put a you know nested
like imagine that json file like how can
you flatten it right how can you put
that nasty structure into a 2d structure
so
the writing procedure is
um it could be quite complicated but i
would summarize it as follow so first i
would um
just convert it as a data frame so i
would get
so everything would be in a json file so
each record would be
you know an entity itself
um you can just use the data frames from
records which is quite good um to
convert it okay
um but
of course most a lot of time it won't
work because of that nestor thing that i
mentioned earlier so the next thing is
to de-ness it like to expand it so
um
in json we have the in pandas we have
the json normalize which is a um
billing method
not really okay again so
so
in pandas we have adjacent normalize
which is a
a function provided by pendus that you
could um
flattened your data frame uh but the
problem is that you may have to do a
little bit of
fine tuning for example uh you may have
to rename the columns a little bit here
like what i'm doing because i want to
see
which um so when i expand
a column like a nester column i want to
see where it came from so i want to
do a little bit of handling there
um also this uh doesn't work um
uh for a you know more more than one
layer nested nesting um so you may have
to go back and check whether you know
everything is normalized um so i do it
like per column so pre-column normalized
and then join them back if they're still
nested then you can
do it again so
our last thing is that you would have to
go to see the embedded objects because
um i mentioned before some of the
objects you know they are they're linked
data so they're referenced by an id so
in that case you would be given an id as
the value of that
column so what you want to do is to use
the id and find the object back and then
embed it so this is the three steps some
of them you need to repeat you know
rinse and repeat so sometimes the
embedded object you get back is nested
so you have to expand it again
so um also the embedding object uh you
may want to set a maximum depth because
um it could some some of the objects can
be linked within the loop right so you
don't want it to be endless so you may
have to stop somewhere if it doesn't
work just stop okay
um
so this is uh almost summarized
everything i've done to build a tool to
convert it they're all with in the
python client of terminusdb
so um i today just touch on a very
specific area of everything about
terminus tv just a tiny tiny bit of
things if you want to know more about
for example how to model your data
as a knowledge graph we had a workshop
yesterday
but like i said it's recorded so
recording may be available in the future
um also we may have similar workshops or
courses in the future so
visit our blog uh or
a chat with us on discord so these are
all clickable links so if you already
grab the slides you will have access to
this um
so
i
do not think i would have enough time
for a small demo how about
um or do i okay i would just i'll just
run a few scripts so hopefully it will
work
fine so it doesn't take too much time so
uh this is you know what i am i was
using yesterday in the um in the
workshop so uh we have a view csv here
so we have employees.csv which is just
an example i can show you what it is
it's just like this okay so now with the
tool that i have saw some code snippets
for you so these that was the tool that
i was building uh i can just put this
csv into pandas well at the background
and then um
use it yeah the slice i would go back to
the first slice at the end so don't
worry i'll give you that um but yeah
like this this is um
i can convert this into thermosdb so
what i'm i can do is to first of all um
do a delete what i already have so
not to confuse everybody so i just
delete what i wrote
oh i have some kind of thing oh sorry i
did something yesterday and i totally
ruined it uh okay so
no demo now i would i'll give you the
slice um link at the end so sorry i i
forgot i made some changes to the thing
and it's not done yet so i'm in the
middle of developing something so it
does not work um but if you're download
so i'm using the development version if
you
so people downl ask questions
um
uh whatever you want to do so
um
yeah i guess that's it
thank you so much um
i'm certain we've learned a lot and
assistant there's certain people here
who have questions
so you can post your question
on the q a
or you can send it on the chat
um if you don't have any questions it's
still fine uh you can still connect with
suga and oh hey uh
socials there's github twitter
and certainly you can find it also on
linkedin
and um you can continue with the
conversation even on slack
so how scalable is terminal terminusdb
yeah so um terminusdb is um so
the storage is built on rust so it's not
like you know because we know that
python has this limitation but python is
not optimized to be you know um that
efficient installing stuff so uh with
terminus db definitely is more effective
and also um
things are more complex so i can't give
you a very solid answer because um you
know i'm not the back-end developer
who's writing in rust but if you really
want to find a solid answer you can come
to you know grab the slides go to other
squad and ask them
um but it's quite efficient that's what
i can tell you because uh
yeah
from what i heard from a team is like
kind of designed to be very really
efficient and compact because they are
stalling these triples and any rust and
all this stuff so
okay thank you so much chuck we have
another question here
um
from is from ikea no
uh i cannot ask how to display
the graph uh on jupiter notebook
yes the jupiter number so that that
beautiful thing right so
i we just have a meeting this morning
that um so background story about that
where's the thing like okay
yeah this this thing so this thing
actually in the past so he historically
this thing
is filled with a you know javascript d3
for those of you who know um
well now it's too much nooks but anyway
um so
it's in d3 so it can be used in the
jupyter notebook um right now this is
deactivated because we have to do some
upgrades to it um but uh today we have a
briefing that like you know the upgrade
is like is the design is there we will
implement them it's it's almost done so
um in the future this will be back in
available in jupyter notebook uh also
you can export it as a html file so it's
all using javascript so yeah
thank you so much duke i'm certain we've
learned a lot
and just a reminder this session has
been recorded and the recording will be
available so thank you very much